it said few Dupont quite like the
British
perhaps even fewer do it like Judith
from West Yorkshire
this is when he was born
1948. that's why it says from cradle
and this is now when it's become king
cradle to Crown what is it that you love
about the royal family it's the best
thing we've got in this country our
monarchy this is also this is our
country and I just wish the younger
ended
they don't seem very kind to them but
there's no sign of apathy here at the
care home where Judith's organized a
party to watch the coronation well how
can you see this and wonder in public
impossible also watching as Keeley whose
brothers in the military who are we
looking out for this one your brother
here yeah what's his name Scott he's
leading the Royal Yorkshire regiment in
the procession it's such an honor to
have my brother in in the coronation and
be part of it something that I'll live
on forever you know but it's something
for him then to show his little boy when
they get older this is tradition
steeped in theater
marked across the country
and across the Nations Millions watched
the king officially become our King
[Music]
in Cardiff the weather was as wet as
that on the day the King's mother was
crowned
[Music]
in Leeds people at Street parties were
thankful for sunniest guys
everyone's together and after everything
the country is being through when the
world's been through this were needed
fantastic we won't never see anything
like that again and it's alive oh it's
marvelous I've seen two I saw the 1953
and this one but there's some changes in
this one that's good
but at this pro-independence March in
Glasgow were signs the new king due in
Scotland this summer for coronation
celebrations might be less welcome
foreign
it's incredible to reflect that today's
ceremony was watched in ways that were
Beyond imagining 70 years ago by people
still decades off being born Louis is a
very cheeky and funny and he's got a
very nice character to him it's
absolutely fantastic that the children
get to experience something like this in
Great Britain the UK having a tradition
like this a monarchy is absolutely
fantastic
and what's a royal do without some
quintessential britishness like a parade
of King Charles Spaniels
cheers wherever or however you watched
this was a moment already now history of
which we were all today apart
Katrina Novato see Sky News